en vísperas de una de las copas del
mundo más controvertidas de la historia
el presidente de la FIFA gianni
infantino realizó una estrategia
defensiva confusa que no le salió
también y que generó una diatriba
sorprendente frente a la prensa
internacional el mundial de Qatar ha
sido fuertemente criticado tanto por su
costo ambiental como por los abusos a
los derechos humanos y este anuncio no
mejora el ambiente hoy me siento catari
hoy me siento árabe hoy me siento
africano hoy me siento gay hoy me siento
discapacitado hoy me siento un
trabajador migrante el presidente de la
FIFA pasó a denunciar las lecciones
Morales de Europa y acusó a occidente de
hipocresía con respecto a los derechos
de los trabajadores inmigrantes
Cuántos de estos empresarios empresas
europeas u occidentales Cuántas de ellas
han abordado los derechos de los
trabajadores migrantes esta elección
moral queda unilateral es puro
hipocresía Juan
la polémica ha dominado la preparación
de la tan inesperada copa en un cambio
de último minuto se prohibió la venta de
alcohol en todos los estadios que
albergan los partidos contradiciendo la
declaración hecha en septiembre de que
los fanáticos con boleto podrían comprar
cerveza dentro de los estadios y a sus
alrededores el propio infantino ha sido
polémico antes en enero pasado se
dirigió a los políticos europeos
explicando que realizar una copa del
mundo cada dos años podría evitar que
los inmigrantes africanos encuentren la
muerte en el mar Pues a las denuncias de
discriminación esclavitud moderna y
corrupción la copa del mundo es una
realidad que se materializará en pocas
horas